hey 42 here there's something
inherently creepy about lighthouses half
of them seem to be haunted
and many have borne witness to terrible
tragedy
in the form of wrecked ships and drowned
men
this spooky quality has made lighthouses
a hollywood mainstay
and only dilapidated victorian mental
asylums
come close to matching them for the
coveted title
of most commonly used creepy building in
horror films
but why exactly is that i mean when you
think about it
a lighthouse is basically just a very
large
very well-made camping lantern and as
far as i'm aware
nobody's ever soiled themselves whilst
contemplating the terrifying mysteries
of the humble hurricane lamp i suppose
it's got something to do with all that
isolation business
stick a single blinking camping lantern
on a barren rock somewhere in the middle
of a storm tossed sea
and it would certainly gain a fair few
creepiness points
especially compared to one just sitting
on the shelf in your local supermarket
add a battered taciturn old man into the
equation
and i guess we're starting to get
somewhere it isn't so much the buildings
themselves but
the sense of extreme loneliness and
seclusion
we associate with lighthouses that get
some of our most primal fears going
factor in their proximity to another
place where
scary norway seems to go down the ocean
and you basically have yourself a recipe
for guaranteed scarce
considering all of this i can only
imagine that
when the captain of the steamship arctur
sailed by the flannen isles
part of the outer hebrides off the
northwest coast of scotland
on the 15th of december 1900 he felt
a deep sense of foreboding in the pit
of his stomach that's because despite
the inclement weather the lantern on the
flannen isles lighthouse
was unlit it was an accident waiting to
happen
being a good citizen of the sea the
captain reported the issue to the
northern lighthouse board
when he made landfall three days later
of course this was a time before mobile
phones had been invented
even your regular old stationary phones
were extremely uncommon
and so the only way to find out why the
lighthouse wasn't operational
was to send someone out to physically
check on it
a ship called the hesperus was
dispatched to the flanan isles fourth
width
but bad weather typical of the region
and let's be brutally honest here
the entire country delayed the vessel
in the end it arrived on the 26th of
december a full
11 days after the captain of the actor
had spotted something was a miss with
the lighthouse
no record survives of what those on
board the hesperus thought they'd find
when they reached the island
and it's difficult to make assumptions
after all plenty of things can go wrong
in such a remote spot
there should have been three men tending
the flannel nails lighthouse at the time
james duckett thomas marshall and donald
macarthur
perhaps the lighthouse keepers had been
laid low by illness
or maybe they'd run out of paraffin or
some other key provision
required to keep the lamp burning hell
maybe they'd simply gone on strike after
deciding
living on a rock in the middle of
nowhere wasn't worth their meager
salary but whatever they expected
the relief team on board the hesperus
found
none of these things what they found
instead
was well nothing
james duckat thomas marshall and donald
mcarthur
had vanished no doubt feeling a little
creeped out at this point the relief
team began to search the island for some
sign
of what could possibly have happened to
the free men but
what they found far from providing
answers
only serve to raise more questions and
decidedly unsettling ones at that from
the outside
the lighthouse looked completely normal
aside from the obvious fact its lantern
was unlit
the gate to the compound was closed as
was a door to the lighthouse itself
but unventuring inside it became clear
nobody had been there for several days
the lighthouse was
almost eerily quiet and the reason for
that
soon became apparent all the clocks in
the building
had stopped years later stories
circulated that the relief team had
found
unfinished meals laid out on the table
and a fire burning merrily in the half
people also spoke of mysterious logbook
entries detailing
colossal ground shaking storms
so violent they've left the seasoned
lighthouse keepers in tears
despite the fact no storms had been
reported in the area
on the days in question all very spooky
but in reality these details were added
after the fact
by over-enthusiastic locals keen to
embellish this tale
which is all a bit unnecessary if you
ask me
this is one story that needs no extra
spice
after finding nothing much of interest
in the lighthouse itself
the relief team began to comb the island
for clues
the largest of the flannel isles eileen
moore isn't particularly big
so the search didn't take too long and
whilst it turned up no trace of the
missing lighthouse keepers
it did uncover a few curious anomalies
the west side of the island showed
considerable storm damage
so considerable in fact that a team sent
to carry out an official investigation
some days later reported that it was
hard to believe
such carnage could have been caused by
just wind
and waves alone we're talking solid
iron railings that had been bent and
twisted
a lockbox that was smashed to bits and
the boulder weighing over a ton
that had been shifted from its long-term
resting place
there was even damage to a small railway
line that had been installed to help lug
provisions up from the shore
the iron tracks had been torn clean out
of the concrete
they'd been set into now sure anyone
who's ever visited the atlantic coast of
great britain
we'll know just how violence the sea can
be in that part of the world
but some of this damage the smashed
lotbox for example
had been dished out some 35 meters above
sea level
and minor damage was found at twice that
elevation
to say this was confusing would be
something of an understatement
short of a tsunami tearing through the
island chain that
the rest of the world just happens to
have missed there didn't seem to be
any plausible explanation for what could
possibly have caused such
severe and widespread damage it was
clear that
something catastrophic had happened on
the island and
recently but what that something was
i mentioned tsunamis a moment ago and
whilst it's hard to imagine a genuine
tsunami going unnoticed in the north
atlantic
even in 1900 another kind of gigantic
wave
just might have snuck under the yet to
be invented radar
a so-called rogue wave which has nothing
to do with the american indie band i
hasten to add a rogue wave is
pretty much what it sounds like a random
huge wave that's
far bigger and meaner than its piers
measuring at least twice the so-called
significant wave height
of the waves around it these freaks of
wave
nature can come out of nowhere and
they're thought to have sunk some of the
biggest
and most robust ships ever built
rogue waves differ from tsunamis both in
how they're formed
and what they look like to keep things
simple tsunamis are caused by
displacement of some kind usually a huge
underwater earthquake that shifts the
ocean floor
but sometimes landslides or volcanic
activity
rogue waves on the other hand are caused
by
yeah we don't know exactly how they're
caused
in fact for a long time oceanographers
didn't even think they existed believing
them to be nothing more than the
tall tales of salt adult mariners
and it just so happens that the largest
rogue wave
ever measured out in the open ocean was
tracked a mere 300 kilometers away from
the flannen isles
so i think you can see where i'm going
with all of this
stranded out in the north atlantic on a
tiny island
our poor lighthouse keepers were washed
away
by a giant rogue wave a monster that
reared up out of an already wild sea
in the middle of a storm and swept clean
over the flannel isles
but wait a second as i've said
the subsequent investigation of the
island found damage as much as 60 meters
upon the cliffs
and 60 meters would be one hell of a
wave
in fact the wave i just mentioned the
largest ever officially recorded out in
the open ocean
was a smidge over 29 meters tall
a big boy indeed that's about the height
of a nine story building
but not even close to 60 meters
but here unique features of the island's
geography
may hold the key the shores of many of
the flannel isles are popped marked with
what are known as
geos essentially narrow inlets
gouged out of cliffs by untold years of
unprovoked aggro from the north atlantic
ocean
the landing point for ships on the west
side of eileen moore
is built into one such geo which happens
to end
in a sea cave when particularly large
waves hit the island from the west
they rush up the geo and into the cave
before exploding up and outwards with
incredible force if a rogue wave were to
hit the island from
just the right angle well that might go
some way to explaining the insane amount
of damage that was found
and more importantly if anyone happens
to have been standing nearby at the time
they surely would have been swept out to
sea by the sudden unwelcome appearance
of tens of millions of liters of frigid
sea water
as for why anyone would choose to be
standing outside in the middle of a
storm
well recent investigations have revealed
that
one of the lighthouse keepers thomas
marshall had been
fined five shillings for allowing some
of his equipment to be washed away in a
storm
not long before he disappeared if the
weather had started to worsen
it's conceivable that he and his
companions would have wanted to ensure
the gear down at the west landing point
was secure
placing them smack in the danger zone if
a rogue wave
struck the one slight issue with that
theory
aside from the fact it's pure
speculation obviously
is the fact that lighthouse protocol at
the time clearly stated that one of the
men
should have been tending the lamp at all
times
but that little kink can be explained
away easily enough
by simple human instinct most people
will be prepared to bend the rules a
little
in a life or death situation perhaps
whoever was tending the light saw a
monster rogue wave
darken the horizon or maybe he simply
saw his colleagues washed out into the
sea
and tried to save them perishing in the
process
this theory also fits nicely with one of
the other small details noted by the
relief team
who found the lighthouse keepers missing
in the first place
one of the keepers oil skins was still
hanging on its hook
by the door oil skins are large
waterproofs worn by
many who work at sea and no lighthouse
keeper worth his sea salt
would ever have ventured out into the
north atlantic storm
without one that is unless he felt his
friends were in sudden danger
and every second counted as far as
theories go
it's a pretty good one it does an
excellent job of explaining all the many
peculiarities of the case
but of course there's no way we'll ever
be able to prove it
too much time has passed and too little
physical evidence remains
if it was ever there in the first place
that
lack of finality has unsurprisingly
led to a slew of other slightly more
outlandish suggestions
being put forward over the years locals
at the time
spoke of giant seabirds snatching the
men away
and of monstrous sea serpents rising up
out of the depths
looking for something to eat on their
lunch break some believe the men
arranged to leave the island in order to
make a new life for themselves elsewhere
or perhaps that they were abducted by
spies
naturally alien involvement has also
been mooted
no we re mystery is complete without
aliens showing up to fill their
demanding anal probe quota
of course this being a lighthouse there
is one other popular theory
i should mention that one of the men
probably donald macarthur who had a
reputation as a volatile individual
snapped and murdered his colleagues
before throwing their bodies
and his own into the churning waves
without any way to reconstruct an
accurate timeline of events
it's hard to come to any definitive
conclusions
for all we know the storm and wave
damage could be a red herring
distracting our attention away from
other
more sinister goings-on but whatever
happened to those men
it's a pretty safe bet it was nothing
good
another reason then to avoid lonely out
of the way lighthouses
just in case you needed one thanks for
watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts
available on youtube spotify apple
podcast
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
link in the description below
thanks